la décision s'est faite attendre mais
hier tard dans la soirée la commission
d'investiture a tranché le candidat lrm
à besançon sera eric alauzet 61 ans
engagé dans la vie politique locale
depuis les années 90 élu député du doubs
en 2012 avec l'étiquette europe écologie
les verts puis réélu en 2010 est sous la
bannière la république en marche
la commission nationale d'investitures
s'étaient réunis à dix jours et avait
tranché assez rapidement le le sujet sur
ma capacité à rassembler et la
profondeur du projet il trouve que là il
ya une éruption très très forte du débat
autour de la parité est un petit peu
déconnecté la réalité du terrain
mais bon hier soir eric alauzet a obtenu
11 voix contre 8
alexandra cordier selon des observateurs
présents les débats ont été houleux pour
départager les deux candidats
en fin de semaine dernière marlène
schiappa et stanislas guérini ont publié
une tribune dans le parisien appelant à
l'engagement de femmes pour les
élections municipales
nous avions plaidé effectivement pour
ses objectifs de renouvellement donner
de la place aux femmes dans la vie
politique engagé plus de jeunesse mais
aussi donner de la place à l'expérience
donc je crois que cette démarche nous
lui avons donné corps j'accepte la
décision tout simplement il ya aucun
regret à avoir la compétition était
belle inévitablement des discussions
vont s'engager entre les deux ex
candidats à l'investiture à huit mois du
scrutin l'issue de la bataille
municipale est loin d'être acquise pour
la république en marche
un récent sondage interne montrerait
même une position plutôt difficile pour
le parti présidentiel
[Musique]